[Music]
[Music]
now pubs the cost of living crisis is
also a cost of drinking crisis and many
pubs across Britain are for various
reasons facing closure this winter I'm
joined Now by Harry Mount who is editor
of the oldie and now part owner part
landlord of the lamin flag in Oxford a
400 year old Pub and Maggie Holmes who
is landlady of the Odd Fellows arms
Harry let's start with you because
you've got a piece in The Spectator this
week where you talk about becoming a
part owner of this very historic Pub
um tell us how this came about well it's
an uh amazing Pub the lamb and flag
which as you say is 400 years old and
it's most famous as one of the two pubs
where the inklings the writer Tolkien
and the writer C.S Lewis drank for 20
years and discussed their famous books
um Lord of the Rings and lion witch in
the wardrobe in both of these pubs and
then very sadly both of them the lamb
and flag the watch the one I bought a
share in and the eagle and child closed
during covid and they've stayed closed
ever since until today the lemon flag is
reopening thanks to a group of 300
drinkers including myself who love the
pub who've got together to save it so
today it's six o'clock it's reopening
which happens to be the 100th 111th
anniversary of the day Tolkien first
went to Oxford and graduate and as all
tolkienologists out there will know
the opening of Lord of the Rings begins
with Bilbo Baggins celebrating his 100th
and 11th birthday or his um uh 191st as
he called it birthday
um as you say in the piece Harry it's
not an investment opportunity this is it
it's a it's a project of of love that's
right I mean um the minimum you could
put in was was a thousand pounds pounds
without what I put in and um others have
put in more than that but I'm not
expecting any return nor is anyone else
I I'm pretty sure it is a labor of love
and uh a love for this Pub where I I
drank at both those pubs when I was at
Oxford 30 years ago and when I heard
both of them were closed during covert
it was a real um kind of one of those
real sentimental blows because you just
thought they'd been open for 400 years
and you had those wonderful pubs you had
the feeling there'd be open for not just
another 400 years but for for the rest
of time so it was a terrible shock and
it's and it's fantastic that at least
one of them is reopening tonight well uh
all spectator TV viewers it's in the
Oxford area or even further abroad
should um visit the laminate flag
immediately six o'clock tonight first
first pints being served yeah uh Maggie
I used seeing uh this there's quite a
lot of reports about how many pubs are
going to close are you seeing this uh
across the country how bad are things
for you at the Odd Fellows arms
I am seeing this across the country
um at the moment we are holding our own
shall I say we are wiping our face we
are there but by no means are we making
a profit that you would think that would
you know sustain and keep us in growth
we are at the point where
we are extremely worried about the costs
and feel that we won't be surprised if
we see you know five in ten pubs close
that's that's the talk across the
business you have to be
um
shall we say really clever with how
you're going to manage this at the
moment because we know that with these
Rising costs it's not you how much can
you actually pass on to your customers
without it being a struggle without it
turning people away we are going to be
the first thing that is hit when people
are looking at what they've got in their
pocket you know this is
um this is a Leisure this isn't a
necessity
um and and we are worried we are worried
about how it is we are as I say
um doing fine here in the most but we
know with the rising costs it is going
to be a real struggle
can you run us through uh the costs is
it is it energy costs is that the the
most energy cost is massive absolutely
massive at the moment we've gone from
1800 pound a month
to almost three thousand pound a month
just for gas and electric so that is
something how do you pass that extra
1200 pound on to customers because it's
got to be found somewhere and that's an
astronomical jump if you're putting in
you know another 20 pence fifty Pence on
a pint
um because it's it's a lot to find for
people and if they're coming out for a
nice night what do the sacrifice
do they go for mail or do they spend
more time in the pub it's it's what
they're going to decide in the long run
which one goes first
what do you hope or do you hope at all
that the government will do anything
more to help pubs I I think pubs will
help quite a lot during covid uh and uh
Liz truss's energy plan will help a
little bit I think with the energy costs
what more would you like government to
do to help the pub industry
it is good that there is there is going
to be a cap
um put on it from from what Liz trust
has said
um which is great but I do think a lot
of places will not survive without
um a helping hand a grant something that
will you know
help us keep the doors open because
these are figures as I've said that will
absolutely [ __ ] most
um public houses Harry uh do you think
the pub which is uh you know facing a
lot of pubs of cross Britain are facing
a lot of difficulties and becoming
increasingly unviable uh economically do
you think it's just going to be
nostalgia in a way your your project is
a certain Nostalgia that's going to keep
a lot of them alive uh yeah no I
undeniably our Pub um is is a lot of in
Nostalgia but it is amazing that even
something like the lamb and flag
incredibly famous pub with this
connection with Tolkien and C.S Lewis
right in the heart of Oxford with
millions of tourists in the doorstep
it went it went uh bust
um and and so Nostalgia wasn't enough
for the for the lamb and flag I think I
completely sympathize with Maggie that
the costs have soared and and the costs
that have obviously already been passed
on to the Drinker of Sword I mean uh
it's easy to be nostalgic but I was 30
years ago I was at University and I seem
to remember that a a point was about
just over a pound then I don't know what
we're charging charging very good prices
but still at the same time uh Maggie and
other um land ladies and landlords have
to um have to bear so many costs it's
not surprising that the point in a pub
is pretty expensive and that's why we've
seen over the last 30 years since I left
University so many younger people
drinking or front loading as they call
it at home before going out on the town
so I'd have thought the government could
do us all a favor and cut Duty uh on
drink perhaps they could even do it just
specifically for for pubs because the
pub is a is an incredibly historic part
of uh British life they go right back to
the Early Middle Ages and some of the
earliest pubs were right by the um
entrance to churches because churches in
a very decent way used to brew their own
beer so it's every time a pub closes
even a one not as historic
um as the lamb and flag is a real blow
so I think the government can do more
and cost is really the big is a big part
of it Maggie that sounds like an
excellent idea to me uh points around uh
this around our office are now six six
or more pounds uh a pint of beer what
are you charging for a pint and do you
like Harry's idea of a a special uh
dispensation for pubs I do like the idea
you that Harry's got from a special
dispensation because it will be a
massive loss if these pubs leave the
High Street you will need to see how
retail has been affected you can go to
any City now I was in Edinburgh the
other week and I was shocked at the
change that I saw in in how many retail
outlets have gone so we don't want to
lose the part of the community and I do
believe that we
do need a help in hand and for example
uh most expensive paint here is Moretti
or San Miguel and that's four pound
forty you know if I have to
um swallow these costs and and I've got
to put it up to six pound fifty well
that's just not doable in a small Beach
it's not it's not acceptable people
won't be coming out certainly around
here and and paying six pound fifty for
a paint it's it's just not you can't
request that for people but if we don't
get the help that is you know what we're
looking at
Harry and Maggie thank you very much for
uh coming on I wish you all the best
with your both your pubs
[Music]
foreign
[Music]